[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans cette
édition spéciale du skyco au Salon
international de l'aéronautique et du
spatial 54e édition au Bourget et encore
une fois le territoire de Saint-Quentin
en Yvelines sera très bien représenté à
travers ses grands groupes ces PME c'est
start-up ou encore c'est centre de
recherche tous engagés dans
l'aéronautique civile le spatial ou
encore la défense et nous parlerons tout
d'abord de la décarbonation de l'avion
ou comment l'aéronautique tente de
réduire les émissions de gaz à effet de
serre à travers des innovations nous
évoquerons ensuite les activités autour
du spatial à travers des entreprises des
startups et des centres de recherche
engagés dans la conception et la
fabrication de satellites puis nous
terminerons avec le secteur de la
défense avec des technologies
développées sur le territoire de
Saint-Quentin en Yvelines et qui sont
implantés ensuite sur l'avion de combat
de l'armée de l'air française le Rafale
c'est au programme de ce numéro spécial
du Sky Eco au salon du Bourget
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tendre vers un avion de plus en plus
décarbonée c'est au cœur de ce salon du
Bourget 2023 et l'équipementier
aéronautique safran a présenté dans ce
cadre-là son programme rise l'objectif
du programme rise est de produire un
nouveau moteur technologique qui émet de
moins en moins de gaz à effet de serre
les détails de ce programme avec Pierre
contorsau Directeur technique adjoint
chez Safran aircraft engine
[Musique]
je suis le Directeur technique adjoint
de safran aft engine en charge des
moteurs pour avion de ligne
le programme raï c'est un programme de
démonstration technologique pour
concevoir les moteurs d'avion de ligne
du futur envoie derrière moi une
maquette de cette open fan de se
démonstrateur rise c'est une maquette à
l'échelle 1/2 la taille réelle de
l'hélice ce sera environ 4 mètres de
diamètre et l'hélice est constituée de
deux ensembles une hélice qui tourne
devant et une hélice fixe derrière
[Musique]
le principe c'est pour réduire la
consommation de carburant on intérêt à
brasser le plus d'air possible dans le
moteur et donc c'est pour ça qu'on fait
une hélice beaucoup plus grande que les
moteurs d'aujourd'hui notre objectif
c'est de faire 20% de consommation en
moins par rapport à nos meilleurs
moteurs d'aujourd'hui les lips qui
eux-mêmes avaient réduit la consommation
de 15% par rapport à la génération
précédente ce moteur permettra de
réduire la consommation en carburant en
augmentant le débit d'air dans le moteur
les lois de la physique nous disent que
c'est plus efficace pour propulser un
avion
[Musique]
bureau d'études de safran attrapengine
qui conçoit ce moteur il est
principalement localisé à Villaroche
près de Melun mais on reçoit également
le support de nombreux établissements de
safran notamment celui de safrantech à
Magny-les-Hameaux qui inclut notamment
des ingénieurs spécialisés en
aérodynamique en matériaux qui viennent
soutenir les équipes de safran aircraft
engine localisés à villarrosse Alan
générique on recrute des ingénieurs des
techniciens pour concevoir les moteurs
de demain les moteurs qui permettront de
réaliser les objectifs de transport
aérien moins carbonés à l'horizon 2050
[Musique]
et derrière moi un moteur lip développé
par safran aircraft engine et ses
moteurs fonctionnent avec bien
évidemment du carburant et ça fera un
travail actuellement pour développer des
au carburant appelé aussi carburant
aérien durable c'est le travail
notamment de plusieurs experts sur le
site de safrantec à Magny-les-Hameaux
nous avons rencontré Nicolas Jolan
expert carburant regardez nous sommes
sur le site s'affronter Kamani les
hameaux avec Nicolas jeulan expert-car
carburant au sein de la Direction R&D de
safrantec bonjour bonjour alors un
premier mot déjà savoir quel est
l'impact aujourd'hui qu'à le kérosène
c'est le carburant utilisé pour faire
voler les avions sur et bien la
pollution engendrée par l'aéronautique
alors actuellement le transport aérien
représente à peu près entre 2 et demi et
3% des émissions de CO2 au niveau
mondial ce qui peut paraître assez
faible ce qui va à peu près au même
niveau que le maritime par exemple ce
sont des chiffres qui sont par contre en
constante croissance étant donné la
croissance du trafic aérien et de plus
il faut quand même rappeler également
que l'aviation à un impact via ses
émissions de CO2 mais également via les
émissions haute altitude les fameuses
traînés de condensation qu'on voit par
temps clair que certains trouvent très
poétiques mais qui malgré tout particip
au réchauffement climatique et donc il
faut ajouter cet effet aux émissions de
CO2 donc souvent on estime que au global
la contribution de l'aérien au
réchauffement climatique doit être aux
alentours de 4 à 5%. mais ça c'est des
choses qui restent encore à valider
alors dans l'automobile on parle de
véhicules électriques véhicule hybride
mais aussi de biocarburant et c'est la
voie que vous avez choisi dans
l'aéronautique le biocarburant pourrait
être une solution du coup pour rendre
l'avion plus vert ou est-ce qu'en sont
vos travaux sur le biocarburant alors
c'est beaucoup plus que pourrait c'est
forcément ce sera nécessairement un
pilier important pour la décarbonation
de l'aérienne tout simplement parce que
les solutions qui sont appliquées pour
le transport terrestre ne peuvent pas
être appliqués à l'aéronautique civile
principalement pour des raisons de poids
par exemple un avion électrique par
exemple on arrivera pas à faire la
mission en est suffisamment de passagers
avec l'état actuel les batteries de même
les aéronefs hydrogène sont dans les
phases préliminaires de développement et
même si on a des ambitions importantes
pour ces aéronefs ils arriveront un peu
plus tard dans le temps et donc de toute
façon ces carburants durables vont être
nécessaires pour l'atteindre de
l'objectif de neutralité carbone de
l'aviation déjà pour décarboner les
flottes existantes tous les aéronefs que
l'on vend actuellement seront encore en
circulation dans une vingtaine d'années
donc ça veut dire que dans les années 45
50 on aura encore ces aéronef qui seront
là et puis bah également de toute façon
parce que pour les aéronefs longs
courriers c'est la seule solution qui
permette actuellement de décarboner et
même à long terme ces vols longues
distances alors on parle de biocarburant
en anglais c'est le Saf Saf pour le
francisé c'est carburant aérien durable
de quoi il est composé aujourd'hui reste
du kérosène quand même ah oui tout à
fait alors l'été on sent important
carburant aviation durable donc déjà ces
deux carburants aviation donc c'est
quelque chose qui doit être compatible
avec les aéronefs existants c'est
quelque chose qui peut être mélangé avec
les carburants actuels à différentes
teneurs et ceci pour l'instant jusqu'à
50%. et puis à cette notion durable vous
avez remarqué moi je parle on parle pas
de biocarburant on parle de carburant
durable c'est à dire que la matière
première qui est utilisée ne compte pas
le tout c'est que l'ensemble du
carburant soit produit de façon durable
c'est-à-dire prouve un impact positif
sur le réchauffement climatique alors
actuellement on a à peu près on a 7
filières qui sont d'ores et déjà
qualifiées c'est à dire que vous pouvez
monter actuellement dans n'importe quel
aéronef n'importe où dans le monde dans
n'importe quel aéroport et avoir dans
les réservoir de l'aéronef jusqu'à 50 %
de carburant fait à partir d'huile
végétale usagée fait à partir de déchets
de bois fait à partir de déchets
d'ordures ménagères ou voire même pour
des solutions un peu plus avancées à
partir de CO2 et d'hydrogène un peu de
pédagogie le carburant c'est fait pour
faire fonctionner ce genre de matériel
le moteur de l'avion alors c'est une
grosse différence qui a entre l'aviation
et le transport terrestre et que dans le
transport terrestre le carburant sert
uniquement à faire tourner le moteur
dans un avion le carburant c'est la
boîte à outils de la violeur
c'est-à-dire qu'ils servent bien entendu
à faire tourner le moteur et là vous
avez un exemple le moteur lip qui équipe
une gamme importante des air 9 cours et
moyens courrier au niveau mondial mais
il sert également à réchauffer la cabine
il sert à refroidir l'huile il sert
calibrer l'avion il sert à l'état de
choses et donc on lui fait subir
vraiment beaucoup plus de contraintes
que un carburant pour le transport
terrestre d'où la difficulté
supplémentaire bien entendu de
développer des carburants pour les
aérien pour être vraiment concret au
niveau des étapes du développement de ce
biocarburant vous avez noué un
partenariat en 2021 avec un groupe
pétrolier français Total
premier vol 100% carburant qui a été
effectué un hélicoptère de safran équipé
d'un moteur safran c'était en début 2022
où est-ce qu'on en est aujourd'hui là en
2023 et pour le Bourget justement 2023
alors en fait on a on va dire qu'on a
deux grands deux grandes voies de
travail pour le développement des
carburants durable le premier c'est la
compatibilité technique c'est ce que
vous disiez à l'instant c'est-à-dire
lever les verrous d'incorporation et
atteindre des possibilités
d'incorporation jusqu'à 100%. donc ça
franchir totalement du besoin de
carburant fossile donc ça c'est
typiquement les travaux que l'on mène
avec notre partenaire total énergie
d'essayer de trouver quel type de
formulation de carburant pourrait nous
permettre d'avoir une compatibilité
quelle technologie il faut mettre
derrière pour que ça fonctionne parce
que bien entendu il s'agit pas
uniquement de décarboner il faut aussi
que ce soit totalement sûr pour le
passage il est pas question de dégrader
la sûreté des vols la deuxième voix qui
est très importante c'est la montée en
puissance de la production actuellement
on a largement moins de 1% des
carburants aéronautiques au niveau
mondial qui sont des carburants durables
on a des objectifs de substitution
quasiment intégrales à nos horizon 2050
ce qui veut dire qu'on est actuellement
à on va dire trois ou quatre millions de
tonnes au niveau mondial il faut arriver
à 400 millions de tonnes en 2050 donc on
a un besoin de développement industriel
de la filière qui est fondamentale et là
aussi on travaille avec un certain
nombre de partenaires dont Total énergie
pour aider au déploiement de ces
filières là au niveau français européen
et international et ce développement ça
se passe ici à s'apprendait qu'à
Magny-les-Hameaux combien de personnes
sur ce site travaillent au quotidien sur
le développement des biocarburants
alors ce qui est assez ce qui est assez
intéressant avec ces carburants c'est
que c'est c'est comme la prose de
Monsieur Jourdain finalement quasiment
tout le monde travaille sur les
carburants parfois sans le savoir des
personnes qui vont faire de la
combustion ils vont travailler sur des
propriétés de combustion des carburants
des personnes qui vont faire
l'architecture moteur ils vont
travailler sur les systèmes de
refroidissement donc sur le carburant au
final des gens qui vont être dédiés à
l'utilité au développement de ces
carburants durables on va dire que c'est
une équipe assez restreinte on va dire
d'une quinzaine de personnes en tout sur
l'ensemble des groupes par contre ben
voilà si on regarde tous ceux qui
travaillent de près ou de loin sur la
technique finalement quasiment tous ceux
qui sont dans le développement de ces
architectures il travaille point
important également il faut rappeler que
ça fera fait des moteurs mais ça prend
fait également toute l'architecture du
circuit carburant du réservoir jusqu'au
moteur et notamment sur le site de
plaisir vous avez des experts qui
travaillent en permanence sur les pompes
les circuits carburants les joints etc
et qui eux aussi sont en première ligne
pour le développement de ces carburants
si Nicolas chenin je vous en prie et
expert carburant au sein de la Direction
R&D de s'affronter la décarbonation de
l'avion passe aussi par ces trains
d'atterrissage élément le plus lourd
dans un avion plusieurs innovations sont
déjà développées par safran landing
system notamment le changement de
matériaux sur les disques de frein
l'utilisation de carbone à la place
d'acier ou encore par l'électrification
des trains d'atterrissage écouter ces
deux ingénieurs du site safran landing
system de Vélizy-Villacoublay
[Musique]
je suis Cassandra Brie je suis ingénieur
bureau d'études oui franprince et ça
prend un système devant moi on a la roue
de la 320 et on a le frein de la 320
donc faut savoir que ce frein là de la
320 va venir s'imbriquer dans la roue on
a les différentes encoches qui vont
venir se glisser dans les différentes
trous qu'on voit ici on a ici un
empilement de disque à un moment donné
le pilote va vouloir freiner donc il va
appuyer sur la on a les
différents pistons qu'on voit ici qui
vont venir se rapprocher du premier
disque l'ensemble va venir se serrer et
on va venir frotter les différents
disques entre eux et puis l'avion va
freiner
qui est innovant dans ce système là
c'est les disques qui sont en carbone
historiquement on avait des freins qui
étaient en acier sur les avions un des
gains majeurs de ce frein qui est en
carbone c'est le gain de masse parce
qu'il faut savoir qu'un frein en carbone
comparé à un frein en acier on est sur
un gain de masse pour un cours courrier
d'environ 300 kg si on prend en
considération que sur la vie d'un avion
1 kg de masse économisée c'est 10 tonnes
d'édition de CO2 en moins si on fait un
petit calcul ça nous permet d'économiser
sur la vie d'un avion environ 3000
tonnes d'émissions de CO2 l'avantage du
frein carbone se limite pas à son gain
de masse on a d'autres avantages et
parmi ces autres avantages on a
notamment le fait que on peut réutiliser
nos freins quand ils sont usés c'est à
dire que nos disques vont pas être
suffisamment épais pour garantir un
freinage donc dans ces cas-là on retire
le frein on s'apprend récupère le frein
et on va venir les régénérer c'est à
dire qu'on va venir donner une deuxième
vie à nos disques et après on va les
remettre sur avion donc ça leur fait une
deuxième vie et ça on peut aussi faire
une troisième fois ce qui fait qu'on a
une économie circulaire de nos freins et
qu'on économise aussi nos ressources
[Musique]
Bruno Clerc ça prend l'en ligne système
Vélizy responsable du département essai
de la division système et équipement
nous sommes au sein d'excellabes le
laboratoire dernière génération de
Saint-Florentin system permettant de
tester qualifier les équipements et
systèmes produits par la division par
exemple on va tester tous les
équipements de distribution hydraulique
qui contribuent à l'extension rétraction
des trains mais également les systèmes
qui permettent de gérer le freinage des
avions ou la rotation de la roue le banc
d'essai que nous avons ici c'est un banc
d'intégration système qui nous permet de
valider l'intégration des derniers
systèmes en particulier notre système
eahydrostatique qui est un système plus
électrique qui permet de gérer
uniquement localement l'hydraulique et
de n'utiliser que l'énergie électrique
de l'avion ce qu'on voit c'est un train
classique d'A320
qui aura les équipements hydrauliques à
la fois de rotation d'ouverture de
trappe fermeture de trappe et
d'extension rétraction et auquel on a on
gère localement en fait la puissance
hydraulique par une moto pompe et un
petit réservoir d'huile tout ça est
alimenté uniquement via l'électricité de
l'avion géré par notre calculateur qui
vient de s'alimenter au juste besoin
quand on a besoin d'effectuer
l'atterrissage ou de fermer les trappes
et de rentrer le train à au décollage on
a plusieurs types de gains dans un
premier gain en masse c'est à dire que
en fait l'avionneur dans le sein de
l'avion n'a pas besoin d'avoir tout un
tuyauterie hydraulique qui vient
alimenter le devant de l'avion le second
gain c'est qu'on est alimenté uniquement
par l'électricité et on vient pas puiser
sur les la partie de l'avion ce qui peut
se passer au sol par rapport à son
électrification c'est on peut imaginer
ce qu'on appelle le it taxi ou roulage
roulage électrique avec l'intégration
d'un moteur électrique dans la roue
avant ou également dans les
atterrisseurs arrière qui permettent à
l'avion
d'être autonome sur son roulage de ne
plus utiliser la puissance des moteurs
lorsqu'il est au sol et d'utiliser ce
petit moteur électrique intégré dans les
roues les défis de demain c'est là où on
a un système hybride électro
hydrostatique le défi de masse peut-être
sur un système purement électrique ou là
on a plus on aura plus d'hydraulique
mais simplement des actionnaires
électriques dans quelques semaines le
ban que vous voyez derrière moi sera
transformé pour on va tester sur un
plateforme d'avion d'affaires un système
complètement électrique
[Musique]
et nous allons maintenant parler
d'ingénierie industriel avec notamment
le Groupe SEGULA technologique est
engagé dans à l'aéronautique notamment
pas que et pour parler de ségulateur
technologies qui est présent bien
évidemment à 50 ans en Yvelines sur son
site à trappe nous allons parler de sa
marque de design industriel technique on
avec Frédéric Loisel bonjour bonjour
responsable commercial et marketing de
cette filiale alors déjà un mot sur
cette filiale qu'est-ce que c'est alors
c'est la marque du design industriel du
Groupe SEGULA donc on est 350 400 dans
le monde en France on est à peu près on
attrape 35 salariés on fait travailler à
peu près 60 personnes par mois et on
intervient depuis l'idéation ce qu'on
appelle le dilemme thinking jusqu'à la
Collective design donc la convergence
qui technique et la qualité perçue sur
des projets industriels alors on sait
que le design c'est très important dans
l'industrie on peut imaginer notamment
pour l'automobile ça permet d'attirer de
nouveaux clients des acheteurs
d'automobile qu'est-ce qu'il en est du
design dans l'aéronautique parce que
finalement les gens
n'achètent pas un avion ils sont ils
prennent et il s'intéresse pas forcément
à l'extérieur de l'avion exactement la
particularité de l'aéronautique un petit
peu comme dans le rail c'est que le
client final c'est pas l'acheteur du des
produits donc on intervient par contre
dans des produits industriels et toute
notre force et la valeur ajoutée c'est
de veiller à ce que l'usager soit au
centre du débat toujours de A à Z du
début du projet jusqu'à la fin et qu'on
n'oublie jamais l'usager final dans un
développement de produits alors
concrètement attrape vous voyez il y a
35 ingénieurs qui travaillent au
quotidien sur le site de trap sur le
design en quoi consiste l'activité alors
des designers industriels donc
l'idéation le design thinking donc c'est
de la recherche du
user experience du sketch donc tout ce
qui est dessin tout ce qui est couleur
et matières tout ce qui est modélisation
3D rapides des usages marketing aussi on
fait des clips des configurateurs des
aides à la vente et après il y a toute
une grande partie qu'on appelle
collective design qui est la convergence
qui technique c'est comment travailler
des ingénieurs mais aussi avec le
produit le marketing les fournisseurs
pour arriver à terme sur un produit dans
la rue ou dans les airs aujourd'hui on
le voit peut-être derrière moi mais vous
pensez notamment le design par exemple
un des sièges qui a dans l'avion
exactement on travaille on a un grand
client un grand partenaire dans
l'aéronautique et safran et on travaille
aujourd'hui dans la convergence
technique donc on développe des sièges
pour eux à leur côté des sièges business
ou des sièges éco et depuis pour
accompagner en fait les bureaux d'études
dans le développement des produits tout
en gardant quand je les disais tout à
l'heure l'usager au sein du débat donc
on fait les sièges l'outil que vous
utilisez aujourd'hui qui est de plus en
plus dans l'industrie dite 4.0 comme on
dit c'est la réalité virtuelle on voit
qu'il y a un casque devant moi de
réalité virtuelle tout à fait alors
comment vous l'utilisez la réalité
virtuelle alors vous allez pouvoir le
tester dans quelques minutes c'est un
outil de travail aujourd'hui c'est à
dire qu'en effet les usages autour de la
réalité virtuelle sont multiples ça peut
être de l'aide à l'avant ça peut être de
la formation du manufacturing ou de
usage marketing aujourd'hui on a
présenté on présente une expérience
d'outils que l'on utilise au quotidien
en revue de design en revue de qualité
perçue pour aider en fait tous les
acteurs d'un projet à converger ensemble
donc les ingénieurs le produit le
marketing les fournisseurs autour de la
maquette numérique donc là c'est avoir
une perception humaine pour avoir un
vrai ressenti de la perception de la ce
qu'on appelle la qualité perçue au final
d'un produit et pouvoir juger et
arbitrer ce qui est important ce qui est
pas important les points durs et là où
il faut mettre du temps et donc de
l'argent et on a toujours sans cesse à
coeur de compresser les temps de
développement donc cet outil nous sert
au quotidien pour communiquer en interne
projet mais aussi pour prendre les
bonnes décisions et aider à prendre les
bonnes décisions vous m'avez proposé de
le tester on va voir le ressenti puis
vous allez nous expliquer en même temps
le fonctionnement c'est parti c'est
parti
bon ben me voilà dans l'avion à travers
cette expérience de réalité virtuelle
Frédéric comment ça se passe est-ce que
vous pouvez m'expliquer en quoi consiste
l'exercice ici alors c'est un outil de
travail donc c'est ce qu'on utilise
quotidiennement lors de ce qu'on appelle
les revues design et aussi les revues de
qualité perçue pour fédérer tous les
équipes d'un projet donc les ingénieurs
le produit le marketing les
sous-traitants autour de la maquette
numérique là l'idée c'est de passer le
moins de temps possible en préparation
de données 3D et d'être en fait Plug and
Play ou dragon drop de la maquette 3D on
va dire Katia pour pas la nommer par
exemple directement dans cette dans cet
outil qui nous sert c'est un moteur de
rendu temps réel qui nous sert à avoir
une sortie casque une sortie en réalité
virtuelle donc c'est une revue on va
faire ce qu'on appelle par exemple des
assessment donc d'une cotation en
virtuel on va poser des pastilles
virtuelles sur le modèle 3D et à noter
faire des remarques pour pouvoir faire
des préconisations et qui après par la
suite vont être prises par les
différents acteurs du projet donc par
exemple des ingénieurs ou des ergonomes
pour régler des problèmes là le principe
ça va être d'aller chercher certains
pictogrammes pour aller tester certaines
manipulations du siège c'est ça
exactement on parle d'usagers au sein du
débat donc il y a de l'usage et donc il
y a des des cycle de vie il y a des il y
a des expériences il y a des
manipulations à faire là par exemple je
peux aller fermer la porte par exemple
par exemple exactement via ce
pictogramme là voilà donc en fermant la
porte on va se rendre compte si on est
vraiment là c'est un siège business
vraiment isolé du reste de l'avion ou
pas si il y a des fuites de lumière par
exemple qui peuvent
limiter l'ambiance la qualité de
l'ambiance lumineuse parce que là je
vois il y a le côté privé le côté alors
là justement on vient de d'illuminer
disons la fenêtre et là on peut
l'assombrir pour être calme et on teste
cette ce cas d'usage quoi voilà il faut
tout tester tout anticiper très très tôt
dans le projet le plus tôt possible
c'est pour ça qu'on passe très très
rapidement de la 2D sur les sketchs à de
la 3D et qui nous permettent en fait de
simuler très très vite et avec surtout
une perception humaine donc des angles
de vue humain des hauteurs des de
l'ergonomie et donc lever des gros
problèmes qui seraient très très coûteux
à modifier beaucoup plus tard dans le
projet pour l'expérience pour le salon
on a trouvé opportun de démontrer en
fait que l'immersif en fait notre
cerveau est très très malléable et on
peut l'amener sur des histoires ou des
expériences de façon très très réaliste
et donc si vous voulez on va on va se
lever ouvrir la porte et voir quelle
réaction vous allez avoir face au mur
la perception du vide est-ce qu'elle est
juste ou est-ce qu'elle est enfin moi
j'y allais petit pas
évident ça démontre en fait que tout ce
que l'on vit en aurait été virtuelle
même en mode projet où on met pas
l'accent sur le rendu c'est pas c'est
pas le but permet d'avoir une perception
humaine qui est très très très fidèle à
ce qu'il va y avoir quelques années
après quand le produit sera réalisé
produit vendu et ici dans les airs bien
merci beaucoup Frédéric Loisel
avec plaisir je vous en prie voilà je
rappelle que vous êtes le responsable
commercial et marketing pour la marque
design industriel de SEGULA Technologies
technicon
[Musique]
l'édition 2023 du Salon international de
l'aéronautique et du spatial restera
dans les mémoires de 50 ans en Yvelines
vous le voyez derrière moi
l'agglomération a installé un stand sur
le salon du Bourget dans l'espace
Île-de-France l'agglomération qui est
venue accompagner de trois acteurs
engagés dans le domaine du spatial tout
d'abord le l'Atmos le centre de
recherche de l'Université Versailles
Saint-Quentin spécialisé dans
l'observation spatiale puis deux
startups astrolab et constellation
technologies je vous propose de
découvrir les travaux et leurs
innovations regardez bonjour je suis
Philippe quétude vice-président
Recherche et Innovation à l'université
de Versailles Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines
et je suis également chercheur au Latmos
impliqué dans les dans les
développements de nano satellite l'Atmos
c'est un laboratoire historique qui fait
suite à un laboratoire créé en 1958 et
qui a toujours travaillé dans le spatial
et donc le l'Atmos veut dire atmosphère
observation spatiale donc comme son nom
l'indique on s'intéresse à l'atmosphère
terrestre et planétaire donc des
planètes du système solaire alors sur
les formations on voit qu'aujourd'hui
notre expertise peut être vraiment
utilisé à former les étudiants et on a
d'une part participé à la formation en
licence professionnelle une L3 qui était
un besoin des entreprises et on a monté
aussi un master qui s'appelle master new
space donc comme son nom l'indique qui
va qui va permettre aux étudiants de
travailler dans le spatial mais aussi
avec une une vision un peu un peu
nouvelle de ce qui se passe aujourd'hui
[Musique]
alors bonjour je suis Louis de Chazot je
suis assistant ingénieur électronicien
au Latmos alors devant moi j'ai à gauche
inspire 7 un anneau satellite et à
droite une fusée sonde Véronique du
centre du service d'Aéronomie donc un
ancêtre du Latmos pour le moment le
l'Atmos a deux nano satellite le premier
qui est parti le 21 janvier 2021 et le
deuxième que vous avez ici une fire 7.7
qui est parti le 15 avril et
actuellement le deuxième inspire 7 7 est
en cours de validation en orbite alors
le travail d'études climatique il a
commencé avec
usqad donc le premier en récupérant les
données de du bilan radiatif donc
l'étude du climat et les données pour
inspire sa tête sont en cours de
récupération il faut imaginer deux
Rubik's Cube on a nos antennes en haut
et en bas pour faire la communication et
nous avons les panneaux solaires
latéraux sur tous les côtés pour
alimenter notre satellite et vous avez
les petits cadrans blancs ce sont les
capteurs qui vont récupérer nos données
scientifiques alors ça va permettre de
justement faire une cartographie du
bilan radiatif
constellation s'appuie sur deux couches
de satellite une déployée en moyenne
orbite relativement distant de la de la
terre auprès de 8000 km complété par une
deuxième coule satellite qui allait
déployer à très basique après de 400 km
aujourd'hui nous avons réalisé tout un
travail d'ingénierie système qui nous a
permis de concevoir et d'optimiser cette
constellation de satellite de
télécommunication au débit nous avons
également
développer des partenariats avec des
partenaires industriels qui seront
associés à notre start-up pour la
réalisation de ce projet nous prévoyons
dès la fin 2024 de pouvoir déployer des
premières capacités en orbite qui nous
permettront de tester des premières
briques technologies de notre projet
aujourd'hui ce que l'on souhaite c'est
pouvoir offrir aux opérateurs des
communications du monde entier une
solution de connectivité par satellite
qui va compléter les services de
connectivité déjà offert aujourd'hui à
travers le réseau cellulaire ou à
travers à travers la fièvre nous
travaillons aujourd'hui sur le
développement de l'ensemble des briques
technologiques qui nous permettront de
réaliser la démonstration de ce concept
très innovant à horizon 2025 2026 et
nous prévoyons par la suite un
déploiement complet de cette
constellation entre 2026 et 2029 une
fois de plus en partenariat avec les
opérateurs de télécommunications bonjour
je m'appelle Mathieu chaise je suis le
directeur technique et aussi le
fondateur d'astrolabe SAS astrolabe SAS
et actuellement incubé à Paris Saclay et
au ski cube de Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines
on est deux cofondateurs et on cherche à
développer la première station spatiale
complètement robotisée faut vous
imaginiez un bidon voilà un module qui
va faire 4 mètres de diamètre à peu près
8 mètres de long pour 3 huit tonnes et à
l'intérieur des robots qui vont conduire
les expériences des bras robots des
microscopes des échantillons qui qui
vendent d'un poste de travail à un autre
dans la station et surtout à l'extérieur
un système qui va permettre de
ravitailler de manière automatique avec
un bras
c'est avant tout les les instituts de
recherche et aussi évidemment sur le
marché commercial les les grandes
entreprises biotech et Pharma pour
qu'elle développe les futurs médicaments
qu'on ne peut pas développer aujourd'hui
au sol l'émission spéciale skyeco au
salon du Bourget ce poursuit direction
Airbus defense and space à Élancourt
plusieurs collaborateurs de ce site sont
spécialisés dans la conception et la
production de satellites envoyer ensuite
dans l'espace une activité qui a
actuellement en pleine évolution avec la
stratégie nexpace engagée par Airbus
defense and space avant de découvrir les
coulisses de fabrication de cartes
électroniques intégrées dans les
satellites rencontres et présentation de
cette activité avec Jean-Luc Maury
vice-président responsable de
l'électronique spatiale chez Airbus
defense and space à Élancourt Jean-Luc
Moury je suis en charge des activités
spéc électroniques au sein d'Airbus dans
notre établissement de d'Élancourt
[Musique]
les activités que l'on mène ici
concernent le développement de
l'ensemble des équipements électroniques
qui sont ensuite embarqués sur nos
différents engins spatiaux
[Musique]
on a à côté de ce marché là des marchés
qui sont plus orientés commerciaux dans
lequel on sait offrir des situations
moins onéreuses à travers une baisse de
nos coûts on est en mesure aujourd'hui
de pouvoir accompagner un certain nombre
d'initiatives à travers les technologies
qu'on maîtrise à travers l'utilisation
de ces nouveaux composants de nouveaux
assemblages cela nous permet de pouvoir
offrir à nos clients des coûts qui leur
permettent eux de financer des missions
qui n'étaient pas finançables avant
[Musique]
on a besoin d'abord une organisation
projet donc avec des chefs de projet
avec des contrôleurs financiers des
contrôleurs planning on a ensuite besoin
d'ingénieurs pour designer ces
équipements donc pour les concevoir on a
ensuite besoin d'ingénieurs pour les
tester puisqu'il faut qu'on vérifie les
performances par rapport à ça et puis
bien évidemment on a besoin de les
fabriquer et pour cela on dispose de
l'ensemble des métiers de fabrication
[Musique]
je m'appelle Adrien privé je travaille
donc à airbusif en face ici en salle
blanche je suis ingénieur de production
ingénieur méthode production ici on
fabrique des cartes électroniques qui
sont intégrés ensuite dans les
satellites pour airbusifs and space mon
travail consiste à mettre en place des
nouveaux produits
l'industrialisation de ces nouveaux
produits notamment et également faire du
suivi de prod global pour nos projets
récurrents on produit plus des
satellites qui coûtent des millions
d'euros et en industrialisation et même
en bureau d'études le nexpace s'est
trouvé une nouvelle philosophie de
production c'est produire avec déjà des
composants grand public donc on est plus
sur des composants spécifiques aux
spatial et c'est produire avec des
nouvelles règles d'industrialisation qui
sont beaucoup plus optimisées depuis une
cinquantaine d'années on a l'habitude
d'envoyer des satellites de par deux
donc des très gros satellites qui
coûtent extrêmement cher maintenant la
nouvelle mode on va dire c'est c'est les
constellations c'est envoyé en fait des
grappes de satellites donc on peut en
mettre 30 40 par fusée c'est des tout
petits satellites pour un ordre de
grandeur un satellite
classique un satellite on va dire
standard c'est de la taille d'une
camionnette un satellite constellation
on va plus se retrouver aux alentours
d'une taille d'une machine à laver notre
carte électronique elle arrive chez nous
complètement vierge donc faut aussi
imaginer comme une feuille qui contient
une vingtaine de couches à peu près on
peut aussi les entre 10 et 30 couches
combat positionné donc ici sur le
convoyeur d'entrée
cette cette carte elle va passer ensuite
dans cette machine qui va nous permettre
de déposer la crème à braser sur la sur
le PCB donc la crème à braser
globalement c'est des petites des
petites doses d'alliage qui vont
permettre ensuite de pouvoir solidariser
les composants sur sur le PCB sur la
carte électronique ici vous êtes sur la
machine de contrôle cette machine elle
va contrôler ce qu'on a fait auparavant
en sérigraphie on va vérifier
globalement que la dépose est conforme à
nos attentes et à nos critères donc
cette machine globalement c'est une
machine qui va prendre des photos en 2D
en 3D de la carte et qui va analyser les
dépôts sur toute la carte on passe un
peu sur la plus grosse machine de la
ligne celle qui va vraiment poser les
composants sur la carte électronique
donc vous avez la chance de pouvoir
l'avoir en action actuellement
et en plus vous avez la chance d'avoir
une carte next face sous les yeux donc
cette carte c'est une carte du projet
one sat par exemple
vous voyez qu'on a quand même une
cadence assez importante là on a une
cadence d'à peu près 7600 composants à
l'heure cette carte là qui possède à peu
près 3000 composants un quart d'heure
elle est
elle est finie on peut observer là du
coup la sérigraphie qu'on a fait sur la
première machine et aussi les composants
qui ont été déposés par la machine
précédemment il faut veiller à ne pas
toucher cette carte actuellement parce
que les composants ils sont juste posé
en fait faut dire que la crème abraser
actuellement est c'est comme une sorte
de dentifrice donc les composants ils
sont juste posés sur du dentifrice il
faut bien vous dire que là on retourne
la carte tous les composants tombent
pour justement solidariser tous les
composants qu'on aura posé sur la carte
électronique
sur cette carte on va utiliser cette
machine donc cette machine c'est ce qui
s'appelle un four eBay un four à
refusion le principe de fonctionnement
il est assez simple on a un fluide à
l'arrière de la machine qui est en
ébullition constante et ces vapeurs
montent à peu près 240 degrés notre
carte elle va rentrer dans ce four elle
va aller au fond au fond du four donc
c'est le fond de la cuve qu'on voit
derrière et la carte elle va faire des
des va-et-vient enfin des hauts et des
bas plutôt pour
braser correctement les composants sur
sur toute sa face là il faut vous dire
que la carte elle est quasi terminée
elle est même terminée parce que cette
machine va pas apporter de réelles
valeurs ajoutées à la carte elle va
contrôler tout ce qu'on a déposé sur la
carte ce qui est essentiel et même
indispensable en vue des critères
qualités que l'on se doit de respecter
[Musique]
à la fin de la ligne auto les éventuels
non conformités qu'on aurait pu observer
sont corrigés immédiatement après par un
opérateur manuel une fois que notre
équipement il est contrôlé vérifié testé
on peut l'envoyer vers nos clients que
ce soit en termes Toulouse ou on a
également des clients externes satellite
on les garantit entre 15 et 17 ans dans
l'espace et contrairement à votre
voiture par exemple si vous avez une
panne il est impossible de le réparer
entre le moment où la carte est lancée
le moment où elle va elle va être
intégrer dans le satellite il se passe
environ 9 mois 9 à 12 mois et ensuite
par contre on va attendre un ou deux ans
jusqu'au lancement réel du satellite
intégré dans la fusée et je vous propose
de rester sur le site d'Airbus défense
and space d'Élancourt pour parler de
défense actuellement une équipe
d'ingénieurs travaillent sur le mdcc
multi domaine combat de Cloud a un
système de connexion entre différents
outils et véhicules de l'armée par
exemple la 330 MRTT l'avion de transport
et de ravitaillement de l'Armée de l'Air
le remote carrière appelé aussi drone
d'appui destiné à accompagner l'avion de
combat ou encore l'eurodrone un drone
d'observation qui sera capable aussi de
porter des armements et il est
actuellement en cours de développement
au sein du groupe Airbus nous avons
rencontré gilbertrand le responsable du
programme mdcc sur le site d'Airbus
defend space Highlander sur le site
d'Airbus defense and space dès l'encours
une équipe d'ingénieurs travaillent sur
le système de combat aérien du futur le
projet européen SCAF ça comprend
plusieurs activités notamment la
création d'un avion de combat de drone
de nouvelles générations ou encore un
système d'information nouveau baptisé
multidomènes combat de Cloud et pour en
parler nous sommes avec le responsable
de ce programme MDC en France
gilbertrand Bonjour bonjour Nicolas et
bienvenue à Élancourt merci de nous
accueillir ici alors justement qu'est-ce
qui se passe ici autour de ce projet MDC
le Cloud du futur militaire c'est ça
exactement donc là vous êtes sur le site
d'Élancourt vous avez environ 2000
personnes et c'est un centre
d'excellence des métiers numérique ça
veut dire qu'au niveau des ingénieurs
vous avez des personnes qui travaillent
sur les données vous avez des personnes
qui travaillent sur les les
communications sécurisées d'autres sur
la cyber protection on va dire sur le
sur le site on a environ 80% de la
population qui est de salariés qui est
ingénieur voilà c'est ça il est en cours
et l'encourt c'est également je dirais
un point pour nous important qui anime
un écosystème un écosystème avec des
partenariats industriels des grands
groupes des PME des startups y compris
donc des entreprises de la région et des
partenariats académiques avec donc des
écoles des formations la communauté de
Saint-Quentin l'ESTACA voilà dernier
message Nicolas au recrute donc si vous
voulez vraiment savoir de l'intérieur de
la machine ce qu'on fait venez nombreux
il y a plein d'offres en ligne on vous
attend et notamment participé donc
conception de ce MDC multi domaine
combattent cloud qu'est-ce que vous êtes
en train de développer par rapport à
cela alors je mdcc c'est vrai ça mérite
un petit peu de d'explication donc sur
le multi domaine première de première
lettre multimetre en français c'est
multimé donc ça les milieux tout le
monde comprend ce sont les milieux
physiques dans lesquels se déplacent les
objets sur le sur l'espace de bataille
donc le milieu terrestre le milieu
aérien le milieu maritime le milieu
spatial et le milieu cyber qui est érigé
en milieu donc ça vous fait 5 milieux et
on englobe aussi les champs les champs
immatériels je citerai notamment le
champ informationnel quand on voit en
Ukraine l'importance de la mano ça c'est
pour la définition vraiment du du multi
multi domaine ou du multiméieux donc de
quoi s'agit-il il s'agit d'arriver à
combiner les effets sur l'espace de
bataille depuis un milieu vers un autre
c'est à dire c'est la mise en réseau de
tous les capteurs qui remontent de
l'information
et en descendant des effecteurs c'est à
dire ceux qui produisent des effets sur
sur le terrain voilà je vais prendre un
exemple ça veut dire pour avoir une
approche multidèle qu'un capteur
embarqué par un avion de chasse peut
détecter une cible terrestre et que la
cible est engagée par un missile tiré à
partir d'une frégate voilà c'est ça
c'est le combat collaboratif vous créez
quoi en fait est-ce que c'est matériel
est-ce que c'est immatériel parce que
c'est de l'informatique du numérique
finalement alors au niveau des
technologies parce qu'ils vont poser la
question vous allez retrouver de
l'intelligence artificielle donc
l'intelligence artificielle sur
plusieurs plusieurs comment dirais-je
segment c'est c'est le traitement de la
donnée avec l'aide de la décision c'est
également dans le domaine de la
communication avec ce qu'on appelle
l'orchestration dynamique des réseaux
alors vous allez me dire ouh là là c'est
compliqué non en fait c'est simplement
changer d'un émetteur à un autre soit un
réseau au sol avec un satellite etc etc
c'est ça c'est permettre des application
je dirais dynamique c'est exactement ce
que fait votre smartphone quand il passe
en permanence de Bluetooth à du wifi à
des réseaux cellulaires mais aujourd'hui
c'est encore très peu présent sur sur
l'espace de bataille donc vous avez un
sujet sur les communications donc les
communications c'est aussi les nouvelles
technologies qui permettent d'augmenter
les débits notamment les liaisons
optiques les liaisons laser là vous avez
un gain assez important ou la 5G comment
on prend en compte la 5G dans les
opérations militaires voilà c'est un
sujet
autrement vous avez toujours sur le plan
des technologies et j'ai cité le cyber
tout à l'heure le quantique le quantique
qui vraiment est une technologie qu'il
faut aujourd'hui maîtriser notamment
pour les les clés de chiffrement et puis
finalement et c'est là qu'on arrive au
Cloud le cloud computing donc le cloud
computing tout le monde l'a vu entrer
dans nos foyers ça veut dire de la
puissance de calcul ça veut dire des
bases de données c'est à partir
desquelles on peut faire travailler les
algorithmes peut-être intelligence
artificielle et je dirais que tout ça
marche si vous travaillez sur les
architectures les architectures de
services alors ça aussi laissez-moi un
petit peu expliquer qu'est-ce que c'est
qu'une architecture et bien si vous
voyez une image d'un espace de bataille
vous allez avoir un chasseur un
ravitailleur un avion de patrouille
maritime un satellite un centre de
commandement un drone un missile tout ça
on va les modéliser ça va devenir des
nœuds des nœuds d'un réseau
et donc l'architecture c'est l'étude
fonctionnelle qui va dire mais qui parle
avec qui quelle est la fonction de ce
nœud là et comment on organise les
choses voilà et ça c'est très important
ce qui est à la fin vous allez pouvoir
mettre en place des services et donc une
service et quelque chose que vous
appelez qui arrive vers vous avec une
application exactement comme sur votre
smartphone exactement une question
simple parce que vous êtes en train de
parler et on le voit un peu derrière
nous avec cette image de connexion entre
les différents appareils les différents
outils militaires est-ce que on pourrait
imaginer question peut-être un peu naïve
mais est-ce qu'on pourrait imaginer que
un Rafale engage un tiers de missile qui
peut être piloté au sol par l'armée de
terre finalement un militaire de l'armée
de terre alors je vais pas m'engager sur
qui va ce que je non mais pour prendre
une image exactement donc mais oui oui
c'est bien l'idée c'est bien l'idée
aujourd'hui les technologies permettent
par exemple d'avoir un avion qui tire
pour reprendre votre expression tandis
qu'un autre va poursuivre le guidage et
cet autre demain si c'est autre chose
qu'un avion technologiquement c'est sur
ça qu'on travaille vous avez
complètement raison
[Musique]
vous en avez parlé c'est la
cybersécurité c'est essentiel quand on a
autant d'outils et en plus d'outils
critiques parce qu'on est vraiment on
parle de l'armée de militaire je suppose
que la cybersécurité est au cœur de du
développement du MDC c'est fondamental
c'est fondamental donc là je dirais le
premier point et c'est vraiment un de
nos métiers cœur que l'on fait avec avec
je dirais donc c'est un secteur
d'excellence d'Élancourt c'est la
sécurisation des réseaux donc ça se fait
d'abord en conception voilà ce qu'on
appelle le bail design c'est à dire
qu'on va à l'avance repérer les failles
que l'adversaire pour pour
je dirais exploiter ensuite ça se fait
avec des outils qui permettent une
surveillance du réseau une analyse des
attaques une proposition d'options de
remédiation des attaques ça c'est la
partie je dirais réseau
classique qui est vraiment vraiment très
bien
très bien maîtrisé ici ensuite si on est
sur un domaine de réseau mdcc défense on
va avoir une autre une autre
problématique qui va être celle de la
segmentation des réseaux des réseaux en
termes de niveau de confidentialité
voilà parce que vous allez avoir des
informations qui vont être source
ouvertes d'autres qui vont être
diffusion restreintes certaines
serontrées secrets défense certaines
seront nationales d'autres arriveront de
coalition ou de l'OTAN et donc on est
obligé de développer des passerelles des
passerelles qui sont des filtres
intelligents des ponts qui permettent de
maîtriser ça et puis je dirais pour
aller vers l'avenir pour aller vraiment
vers le numérique là on a parlé j'ai
parlé un petit peu des systèmes
d'information ou des tuyaux on travaille
directement sur la donnée déjà est-ce
que c'est une donnée de confiance voilà
est-ce que c'est une fake news etc donc
là on développe des outils justement
c'est le domaine de la lutte
informationnelle dont j'ai parlé un
moment donné ça fait partie de l'Ukraine
ça fait partie du sujet une fois qu'on a
qu'on a une donnée de confiance il
s'agit de la marquer de la chiffrer
d'être capable également de voir qui a
besoin d'en connaître et de le faire si
on peut au niveau de la donnée parce que
ce qu'il faut comprendre les normes
avantages c'est que si vous arrivez à
faire ça vous êtes beaucoup plus libre
vis-à-vis des canaux vis-à-vis des
tuyaux voilà et C'est un sacré challenge
et on travaille dessus un challenge en
cours de développement alors quels sont
les prochaines étapes alors à l'heure
actuelle alors premier point ça a déjà
commencé donc je dirais l'étape c'est
celle qu'on vit on a déjà des modules
d'intelligence artificielle qui font de
la de la de la reconnaissance par
exemple d'images ou de la voix on
travaille sur de l'intelligence qui fait
du drone en essence si vous voyez il y a
certaines images qui sont maintenant
assez frappante donc c'est une réalité
deuxième point je dirais qu'à l'horizon
2025 donc c'est demain pour pour Airbus
et demain on travaille sur cette
architecture de service pour avoir la
plus grande compatibilité voilà c'est
très important parce que ça commande
également des affaires de connexion et
je dirais d'interopérabilité c'est
exactement comme votre montre votre
téléphone et votre tablette
ça marche bien quand c'est la même
architecture sinon c'est pas les mêmes
services c'est exactement ça donc on
travaille sur cette architecture de
service à l'horizon 2025 en 2030 en 2030
donc on va encore faire un effort sur le
combat collaboratif dont je vous parlais
donc typiquement c'est largage de drone
depuis depuis la 400m c'est
l'Eurofighter avec un drone un drone à
côté multiplicateur de force et donc
cette combinaison de moyens habiter non
habité voilà et puis 2040 vous l'avez
cité au début c'est donc le Scaff avec
avec un nouvel un nouvel avion de combat
mais je voudrais pas rester sur cette
cette idée d'étape en fait c'est un
processus continu c'est un processus
continu tout simplement parce qu'on
accompagne la transformation digitale
des armées voilà
merci beaucoup gilbertrand merci Nicolas
merci pour ces explications et je
rappelle que vous êtes le responsable du
programme MDC en France pour Airbus des
Finson space et l'avion de combat qui
équipe actuellement l'armée de l'air
française et bien c'est le Rafale bien
évidemment développé par le groupe
d'assaut aviation mais avec de nombreux
partenaires parmi ces partenaires il y a
le groupe Thalès et notamment le site
d'Élancourt qui participe au
développement de ce système de détection
juste au dessus du nez du Rafale mais
aussi de ce système encore pour de la
détection le système talios et nous
avons rencontré Michel Blancard qui
travaille sur le site d'Élancourt et qui
développe ces deux systèmes regardez
[Musique]
le groupe Thalès est un groupe important
spécialisé dans la défense et il est
situé sur le territoire de Saint-Quentin
en Yvelines et avec moi Michel Blancard
bonjour
responsable des lignes électroniques sur
le site d'Élancourt au sein du groupe
Thalès alors c'est quoi le chronique
tout simplement alors l'opening en deux
mots c'est l'association de l'optique et
d'électronique donc on va avoir des
capteurs comme la photographie et on va
avoir des traitements qui vont permettre
d'améliorer les rendus et d'avoir des
fonctions complémentaires et alors vous
vous occupez de l'autre unique de
l'avion de combat de jamais de l'air
français le Rafale oui oui alors le
Rafale entre autres d'autres avions
également mais oui donc nous avons des
produits phares sur le sur le secteur le
pote de désignation laser thalios ou
l'OSF qui équipe tous les deux leur a
fait alors quels sont est-ce que vous
pouvez nous décrire justement ces deux
produits alors oui je peux essayer de
vous décrire rapidement donc le pote de
l'utilisation laser ça va être un pote
qui va permettre de faire de l'imagerie
donc fournir du renseignement image au
pilote également de la désignation de
cible et de l'identification donc en
fait c'est les yeux du pilote et ils
vont porter plus loin pour lui permettre
de réaliser ses missions au-delà des
portées habituelles
et sur le SFI RST on est plutôt sur la
notion de radar donc en fait on s'est un
radar optronique on va scruter l'espace
en face de l'avion détecter les menaces
et lui permettent de les identifier
visuellement par une image
[Musique]
alors tu as laissé historiquement située
sur le territoire de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines et plus
précisément à Élancourt c'est 2000
personnes au quotidien qui travaillent
dans les locaux sur la partie obtenue
oui c'est 2000 un peu plus de 2000
personnes oui et 1000 personnes qui sont
consacrées à ces deux produits là alors
ces deux à la ligne de produits en
général mais oui si en englobe puisqu'en
fait la particularité du site c'est que
l'on couvre la totalité du cycle on
développe les produits on fabrique les
produits on fait le soutien de ces
produits et on gère les programmes sur
la durée totale donc effectivement on
est capable d'adresser depuis la phase
de conception jusqu'à la phase de
soutien concrètement c'est quoi
ces produits alors on a une population
essentiellement d'ingénieurs après on va
avoir différents métiers électroniques
bien entendu puisque vous imaginez bien
qu'il y a énormément d'électronique sur
ce type de produit
informatique puisqu'on a des algorithmes
qui tournent et des logiciels qui
tournent dedans tout ce qui est bureau
d'études mécanique puisque on va être
fixé sous un avion d'armes donc avec des
contraintes mécaniques importantes
optique bien entendu puisque le métier
de lochronique a lit l'optique j'en
oublie sûrement et je me laisse déjà
auprès de ces gens-là et effectivement
donc c'est une population assez large
dans des métiers qui vont être la phase
de conception donc partir d'études
jusqu'à la réalisation de prototype leur
certification pour pouvoir voler sous
les avions de nos clients la fabrication
puisse une fois que le Produit est
défini et qualifié il va être vendu donc
là on va produire ces équipements en
série pour les pour les forces et le
soutien donc en cas de panne de pouvoir
assurer le soutien de nos équipements et
c'est de l'ingénierie de précision parce
que là on parle vraiment de militaires
de défense et forcément il faut que ce
soit certifié par les différents corps
d'armes et vos différents clients alors
on a une exigence de rigueur bien
entendu effectivement puisque on fait
des produits du haute technologie et on
a un mélange de technologie de la
mécanique de l'électronique donc oui il
y a il y a un domaine global appréhender
à titre d'exemple sur 2023 on cherche à
recruter plus de 400 personnes juste sur
le site d'Élancourt donc ça ça vous
donne une idée de de la croissance et de
la dynamique du secteur quel type de
poste alors tout poste
parti technique mécanique électronique
gestion de programme vraiment
toute la partie que je vous ai décrites
peut-être un peu plus sur la partie de
développement effectivement
effectivement avec des ingénieurs
diplômés plutôt électroniques
informatique optique mécanique et si ces
activités vous intéressent n'hésitez pas
à aller chercher plus d'informations et
peut-être à postuler sur le site
internet qui s'affiche en bas de l'écran
merci Michel Blancard merci je vous en
prie je rappelle que vous êtes le
responsable de la ligne de production
électronique au sein du groupe Thalès à
Élancourt merci c'est la fin de ce
numéro spécial du skyco au Salon
International de l'Aéronautique et de
l'Espace merci de l'avoir suivi une
émission que vous pouvez revoir en
replay sur notre site Internet ou sur
l'application mobile à bientôt sur TV 78
[Musique]